Here's some good news.
You know, everyone's reading
the bad news all the time.
I like to focus on the good news,
and I like to use this
accent when I do it.
Over 100 million Americans have received
at least one dose of the COVID vaccine.
That's fantastic, yeah.
And clear signs of hope
that we are nearing the end
of the pandemic are all around us.
And I was watching television
last night and I saw,
well, I saw a sign of that hope in an ad
that ran on TV just last night
around 10 o'clock at night.
I recorded it 'cause
I think this is a sign
that maybe we're turning a
corner on this COVID thing.
Check it out.
[Announcer] People are getting vaxxed,
so guess what's coming back?
Mouths!
(upbeat instrumental music)
♪ Mouths, mouths, mouths, mouths, mouths ♪
♪ Get ready for mouths ♪
♪ Take off your mask
and show us your mouth ♪
♪ Mouths, mouths, mouths ♪
♪ Mouths, mouths, mouths, mouths, mouths ♪
I have no idea what they're selling there.
Yeah, I don't either.
I kind of want to call the
number just to find out.
Yeah, oh I definitely will,
the minute we're done
here, I'm on the phone.
Okay, (laughs) good.
I also found it kind of erotic too.
Yes, of course.
That's just me, I've
always been, you know.
[Andy] Mouths.
That way long before
COVID, I was into mouths.